so we're up against a master thief
assassin high performance driver
[Music]
who is he
welcome to your weekly ticket
we just got our first sneak peek at the
new supergirl costume
the flash director andy muschietti took
to instagram to reveal the first look at
the costume for the character who will
make her new dc movie debut in the film
and while the image doesn't reveal the
full suit it does show that the same
symbol used on henry cavill superman
costumes
will be a part of supergirl's dceu look
sasha kaye will be making her feature
film debut playing cara the character
who is superman's cousin in the
flashpoint inspired flick
previously muskietti also shared the
suits for the flash and one of the
batman suits from the film
zoe kravitz will be making her
directorial debut with a thriller titled
[ __ ] island
which she also co-wrote and will
co-produce the film stars channing tatum
as a tech mogul with a private island
and it follows a young clever woman
named freda who works as a cocktail
waitress in los
angeles who is determined to link up
with him as for the title kravitz told
deadline
as a woman in general and a woman in
this industry i experienced some pretty
wild behavior from the opposite
sex and it alludes to this time and
place we claim not to be in anymore in
terms of sexual politics
people are evolving and changing but
there's still a bad taste in a lot of
people's mouths from past behavior
and gerard butler will be reprising his
role as john garrity in greenland
migration a sequel to the action
thriller greenland
in a continuation of the story the
garrity family who survived a near
extinction level event when an
interstellar comet hits earth
must leave the safety of the greenland
bunker and embark on a perilous journey
across the frozen wasteland of europe to
find a new home
the sequel is expected to begin shooting
next year
the wait is finally over fast and
furious 9 is in theaters
this friday and fandango correspondent
nikki novak had a chance to chat with
stars chris ludacris bridges
and director justin lin about what it
was like to send characters
into outer space in this film before
tom cruise richard branson elon musk
everybody
teds and roman went to outer space you
inspired it according to justin
your existential crisis inspired it so
when you found out
tell me about that moment did you read
the script did somebody call you and
tell you guess what this is finally the
film
we're going to the final frontier i had
to read the script two things every time
i get the new script i always look is
ted's going to stay alive in this damn
franchise
and then number two what can we do that
we've never done before and as soon as i
read that
i was jumping for joy i loved it i was
like i couldn't i wouldn't have never
thought of that
ever really well it almost seemed like
because
you know people have teased it you know
people have talked about it for so many
films now like when was it going to
happen the fact that it was the two of
you
and they chose to make it so funny
like laugh out loud everybody was
screaming in the theater watching it
just give me a sense of what it felt
like to film it like the water
everything was so perfect and how much
riffing went on and how much is on the
cutting room floor like could we have a
director's cut of just the two of you
like riffing that is such a great
question because they cut a lot of it
out of
us being suspended in air and defying
gravity
because of you know the space uh trying
to emulate space
and one it was very uncomfortable
because
how we had to make it happen and and
being on harnesses and things of that
nature and in these
spacesuits that were hot as hell was
uncomfortable but on the other hand it
was absolutely phenomenal because we
knew we were
you know breaking new ground and doing
something that was going to transfer on
screen the way that you just said it
would
it totally did so how is it hanging in a
harness was that the first time you've
done that
very uncomfortable trust me we had to
put on like two different suits
underneath
and then like these belts that had to
get straps and then put on
all of the spacesuit uniforms we were
sweating we were uncomfortable but again
we do anything in order to get that
right take
so that when people go to the theaters
they're like yo this is the most amazing
scene that's what it takes the sacrifice
i heard you say that you and vin looked
at each other and you said
fast nine this is the one this is where
we're going to outer space
was it when you locked eyes with each
other what was that moment that you had
that divine
understanding between the two of you why
was this the one because you could have
waited
till the final film yeah it's
interesting because we've always kind of
talked about all these crazy ideas you
know and
as i was working on it there was uh we
were working on
roman and tej and roman's having a
little bit of an existential crisis
and i was sitting there going wow where
is this going to lead and then it
somehow just kind of
went to space and i thought wait am i
crazy so i called i called vin and i
said hey man i got to come over
i went to his house i remember it was
around christmas because the trees were
up and everything
and then we looked at each other i
talked to him and we looked at each
other and we're like
yeah let's do it you just knew yeah this
is the one and the cast even talked
about those jurassic world
spin-off rumors toreto and a t-rex
please i knew it was coming
oh god i knew it was coming
the jurassic world thing sounds pretty
like crazy
so i mean why not of course i'd be down
for it
um i think it'd be really i mean i feel
like everyone hears these ideas and then
they go
no and then like me why not you know
what i mean
like why not crazier things have
happened
also i love bryce dallas howard i think
she's so amazing so like any
excuse to work with her yes five years
from now
remember you said that okay ah that's
all i'm gonna say
also in theaters this week is werewolves
within and lansky
maybe i'm a werewolf maybe you're a
werewolf
maybe you're a werewolf you're aware
a snowstorm traps town residents
together inside the local inn where
newly arrived forest ranger finn and
postal worker
cecily must try to keep the peace and
uncover the truth behind a mysterious
creature that has begun terrorizing the
community
the horror comedy is an adaptation of
the ubisoft video game
and stars sam richardson and melana
vaintrub
and available to watch on voodoo is
cruella
and spirit untamed
you always tell me get her
this doesn't have to be a scene it
really really does
i'd like to remind you all that i'm
doing this in heels
what was your name cruella emma stone
stars in disney's cruella the
live-action feature film about the
rebellious early days of one of cinema's
most notorious and fashionable villains
the legendary cruella deville the film
is set in 1970s london
amidst the fashion and punk revolution
and follows a young grifter named
estella
who is determined to make a name for
herself with her designs
one day estella's flair for fashion
catches the eye of baroness von hellman
a fashion legend who is both
devastatingly chic
and terrifyingly cunning their
relationship sets in motion a course of
events that will cause estella to
embrace her wicked side and become
cruella
the film holds a fresh rating of 74
on the tomato meter and an audience
score of 97
all right well that's it for this week
but before you go
leave a comment and let us know what
you'll be watching this week
i'm kale and i'll see you next time